oh
hey everybody let me check my mic test
test test test
test got that turned down all right just
thought of something else
all right let's get that right
all right mute this there we go
all right hey everybody welcome
back uh to another live stream
i am sam from python basics and
uh bo and uh quincy and everybody at
free code camp
allows me to come here every other week
and do a stream and i'm super grateful
for that and i'm always very excited
and we have quite a few people here
today so
if you're new here thanks for joining us
um
we usually just do a stream
from videos that i have done before on
my channel and there is a link
down below to that channel um
so if any time there's anything you
don't quite understand or if i've gone
over their micro videos of everything we
have done here and also
this is beau does a very good job
all of these are cataloged
on a playlist on free code camp's
youtube channel after this you can just
click over there
and check out this is this is live
stream 12
i believe uh cardinal you may correct me
or not and we do have
this is the 12th there you go cardinal
does an awesome job for us he is our
moderator so he will keep us on task
um and uh cardinal just
fyi i've done a better job i got discord
open so
there's anything you need to let me know
that i will see specifically just
hit me up over there on our dm
okay so there are a couple things um
nope not the fourth or fifth uh
yes there will be replayed all right i
hope the background isn't too bad i
had to move some stuff around but okay
uh let's just go ahead and get started
so there are a couple things that i do
want to cover
uh first that you we
may not be aware of so we're going to be
doing a random
password generator should have put that
right there
random and um
and if you are new you do not know yet
that i cannot spell so you will see
misspellings typos
everything so that's don't
don't uh don't be alarmed you will
probably catch
um you will catch many typos so
all right so in this password generator
what we're going to need
from python is of course something
with uh random and then so we're not
having to type in all of our
uh letters and characters we're going to
use
uh the string module so let's just go
ahead and look at let's bring in
random first and put that into memory
and really learn learn about it so what
in the world
does random do all right der
random all right
all right cool all right
so well let's look at everything about
it
so it is a module that the core
developers
have already created for of four of us
to random
variable generators now we're going to
touch on towards the end and also stay
tuned until the end because we're
probably going to get through this
uh in under an hour and i have some
extra stuff
that i wanted to talk to that i'm going
to sneak in at the end
so there if you haven't heard
pseudorandom there is no real random
there just isn't because a human being
will begin to
uh repeat digits there's actually that
that is no noticed and then a computer
is based on logic so these are actually
called pseudorandom
and i have a thought and an idea to
actually go over a little bit
of how that is actually deduced how a
random number is actually
calculated so but we need uh randomity
um i think i just made that word up uh
randomness
and um then the actual characters that
we're going to be using
so what we're going to what we're going
to use
in our example is let's get to the
bottom
we're going to use choice
see so help random
choice choose a random element from a
non-empty sequence
all right that's pretty self-explanatory
then we're going to use
shuffle so we need to look at this and
how how we use it
full all right uh
i'm sorry just looking to see if there
was any
all right so shuffle this is super
important
uh and i like to really make a big deal
about in place
and um return
so shuffle does in place
it creates nothing it doesn't return
anything so
and you're going to pass it the sequence
the
list list there we go
so now now let's look at string
so string is another module that the
core developers
have created for us and let's look at
this before we get into it ah
all right as key
the characters that a computer knows
how it tabulates and keeps up with all
key strokes so every character is a
signed
and as key variable
so we'll look at these momentarily but i
want to go over them right now
as key letters as key lowercase
as key uppercase as key
digits as key punctuation
so let's just jump at it so string
as this is another one that i always
have a hard time with so if we look
really close
all right you got can you even use this
in frame this is in frame
all right we have lowercase
and uppercase lowercase and capital
excuse me or uppercase i don't know how
all right so 52.
so 26 letters and the
english alphabet 26 we have lowercase
and uppercase so that's 52. now
letters is both lowercase and uppercase
so we can actually break this out
string dot as
as key lowercase
and boom i just get lowercase and then
uppercase boom capital all right
okay anything anything notable oh jan's
here
awesome oh jan please after after this
um uh hit me up on discord i want to
make sure we get you
to be a uh moderator too
uh because you've been around a while i
think you sent me some stuff but that
was not well
we'll talk about that later uh glad to
have you here
um and glad to have we got quite a few
people here today so glad we have
a pretty large group and start asking
questions if
i have gaps right now please please ask
any questions because this is
when you ask a question somebody else
has that same question
okay so oh i think i was shaking the
camera
string digits all right oops
uh what'd i do wrong string dot
digits
there we go so i get zero zero one two
three four five six seven eight nine
uh string yes uh is that what i did
sting
thank you good catch look i i own what i
can and what i cannot do
uh typing i actually be i actually used
to be a worse typer
before um i began programming because
you have to type these things right
all right oops
sorry i thought i heard discord
all right all right
okay so now that we have our
base modules that we're going to be
using
now we need to begin to create our
function
so we're guess what we're going to call
this function so we're going to call it
password
now now we need to deal with some
things that we you may or may not be
aware of
so we're going to be creating this
function
with um
with some variability so we're going to
need to take in
arguments now some of them are already
going to be set
that we're going to have a starting
point so
if you haven't heard the term default
argument
or optional argument comment right now
because we're gonna get into it so if we
need to go
further into it just let me know because
let's just look at one of our
highly used highly used
uh functions right here print
so like i've done before so
these end perfect example end is
optional
and it is defaulted to
new line that's what that means so when
you have
a so i have to pass
so when i'm using uh
some it is expecting an iterable
it needs to have one argument so then if
i pass
so right here takes at least one
positional argument
zero is given so we're going to set it
up where we're gonna have one
one uh one positional and then two two
optional
all right so let's just look and see
what that is going to look like
uh yeah if we have time we can look at
uh how to replace
um uh
methods with with lists okay all right
so what we're gonna do is we're gonna
we're gonna we're gonna layer this
password generator
to um let's see
how did i want to do this we're gonna
have this
hat be able to take digits and we're
going to control the strength we're
going to have
let me get it up
we're going to take length is it going
to have digits
and the strength of it we're going to
have three scenarios weak strong
and very now we need to pass this
information
on to the user
and and how do we pass information
on to the user
of our function we have to use a doc
string
strength
strength and
we're going to set this up to true right
now all right
so doc string anybody have any questions
of what
a doc string is
okay so the doc string is literally just
this right here this is the doc string
documentation
string and this is
passed along with
our three quotation marks and we're
going to tell the user
what information they need to know so
length
of password
if you
num if you
want a number
and then
and strength
we're going to pass in week
and i moved my camera so if i i'm
squinting more than or excuse me i move
my light
so i would get rid of shadows so if i'm
squinting a little bit more than normal
that is why so all right length of
password
num if you want a number and strength
weak strong and very
so that is what is going to happen
if we then call password
so now i have my documentation string
right there boom let's do this again i
wanted to be able to see if this was
installing frame
shoot is it yeah sorry guys
all right let's move this up just a
touch because i had a
multi multi-line there we go
boom there we go so whatever you type in
your documentation string is the
information that's passed along when you
begin
so then the user understands and you can
communicate even
more in depth and then of course
when you can even have even more but
we'll deal with that at a later time
all right so
okay any anything before we move on to
the actual structure
of of the function
anything good jan cardinal anything i
need to know about before we move on
that i might have missed
okay is that light too bright do i look
all washed out
no okay all right so now we just need to
jump
at it all right where
are the notes i need to get that ready
all right so we don't need pass anymore
so now we have
excuse me so now we need to begin to
account for our scenarios
so we're going to have so we're going to
take length
then we're going to have weak strong
and very so we need to account for we'll
deal with num
in a minute but right now we need to
have three scenarios
thank you misspelled strength
let's see did i do it right that time is
it getting better is it getting closer
okay
awesome
all right
thank you cardinal i don't know exactly
what you deleted but awesome
okay all right so we're gonna need an if
and then
actually let's get our variables going
first so we need to start separating
these
so we're gonna have string
as key lower
and we're gonna have upper
because we want to we want to
differentiate between these and we're
going to have
relative strength and move on from there
as key as
key upper
now let's do digits
and we know that's okay one two
and then you might say why didn't you
just do this well
i want to just have some consistency
here so i'm going to do
lower and it's less typing lower
plus whoa
i hit my i did page up
yeah that's what i did upper then digits
string dot digits
and then punctuation punk'd
string dot
punk punk'd i always i didn't know i
misspelled this i don't think i'd
actually ever
punked tuation and then our password
we're going to increment this so we're
going to start out
with a empty string all right any
all right
all right well everything that i do on
this stream
and also basically over on my channel is
if somebody is beginning to watch this
and has zero experience with
programming and especially python that
um you can jump in follow along and it
can make sense we keep this
as basic as possible and try to move
very slowly into advanced areas so i
hope that answers a couple of the
questions that i just kind of saw
all right because they're because
programming can get very overwhelming
very
very
quickly if strength
equals week so now i can change this to
weak
all right pass all right so now i have
so i'm going to default this to weak
boom all right so now so as you go
through and as you change one thing
change
don't don't write this whole thing at
one time
and then try to run it because you're
going to make a mistake
i don't know if you've if you've been
over to my channel and seen the
um seen the video on
incremental development right right one
functionality
test it because you could have it fail
you you could write
uh you could write a whole section
and it begins failing all over the place
and you have no idea where to start
so write one thing to change test it
move on because
when you go back and you start changing
one or two and the whole thing just
fails
you just want to rip your eyeballs out
so all right
let's just incr incremental incremental
incremental
incremental improvement incremental
change all right
so there there's my little there's my
little soapbox for today
all right so we have this
now this is how we're gonna handle
uh any digits
excuse me i've been a little congested
recently
all right so actually
let's build on this so four we won't do
the numbers
yet so 4
i in
range length
then
let's see where i am
then i'm going to take my password and
i'm going to increment
it up with my random
choice from lower
and actually i just thought about it we
didn't actually
no we we did look at choice right yeah
okay it's going to
randomly pick so i'm going to randomly
pick
from lower so right now week is just
dealing with
the lower case letters and that's it
so if i pass it and we already have it
set on weak
so if i do password
and i pass it 5
i don't have it printing out anything
print pass word
actually this needs to be return
pwd
there we go so i have a password
that is then
print password
five to make it look a little bit
prettier
there we go so of course it's gonna be
random
again so just just like so so now i have
a five letter password but they're all
lower case
so that scenario is again pretty weak
so now let's add well what happens if we
want some numbers
so now let's add some functionality that
if
num so
now why did i just do
if num and length
increment down two
then for i in range
2
password
random choice
digits
and move on so all right now let's go
over this
so now i just hardwired this
so if false
so it's defaults to false so it's not
going to include a number
unless you change it to true then if
this is
true because this is
so now if i go
known num
equals true
so now when this catches true
this is going to reduce so we're we're
defaulting and hardwiring this into
i want at least two of my
two of my characters to be digits
so i'm removing this down making this
shorter by two
then i'm going through here
two times grabbing two digits then
continuing on
so now let's run this so now let's run
this again
now if we look we will deal with this
later with some
randomity randomness should have
probably looked that up before i started
to be able to conjugate randomness
so i'm going to have two random numbers
at the beginning
and then the remainder
of them will be characters so now that
is
our week so now let's do
something with strong and we'll deal
with this
in a minute so i had my if that's my
first condition
and then l if
strength equals
strong
so now what i want to do
is i want to then include
both uppercase and lowercase
and strong and then for
with vary we're going to add punctuality
too
punctuation not punctuality i knew that
sounded weird
sorry we're going to add punctuation to
to our random password all right
okay so now so now we saw what we did
with numbers so we're gonna do
num if and let's see what we
did we're gonna go so now with
strong we're going to keep this as two
and then with very we're gonna add a
little bit
of
flexibility and a little bit more
randomness so that's why
we're not over we're not blanketing our
number choices
and then we want them to be very they we
want them to vary
each each of these so all right
let's see so we got let me get where i
see where i am with my notes
we're on strong so same thing
we're going to lengthen by
2 and then for
for i in range 2
then password increment
if i can increment my typing's not that
great today everybody so i apologize
uh then our random choice
random choice
digits and then we'll come out here
and still do our passwords but now this
for i in range
blanks
now here's where it's going to change
where we're giving a little bit
more depth of character
we're going to use choice
dot letters
and actually
all right so since i already created
this and you may have typed this so
we'll leave letter and letter the same
so now we have upper and lower case here
let me check my indention something
didn't feel right
all right so now we'll leave that copy
paste and then
now we're going to have
strength
and this is going to be strong
all right does everybody understand what
i'm doing so far
all right so
let's see
all right
all right so now i have my strong and i
have five here
let's up this to ten
so now i have up i have digits
capital and lower case all in together
but as you'll know we have a problem
here
where it's
it's too consistent it's it's if
somebody starts seeing this they're
going to realize all right so
i only have to pick there's only digits
at the front
so we need to we need to handle this
right now
so random dot shuffle
and we're going to have a problem here
in a minute so
wait a second shuffle a list
hmm so that's a problem
so we need to come here and go password
equals list password
we need to turn this into a list
then we pass this
so now now let's look and see we're
gonna have another problem
aha what is our issue
what to remind you because this is what
so help what did random
what did random uh shuffle do
who remembers in the doc string random
not
shuffle it's a very big
issue that you have to pay attention to
when you're reading the documentation
this is it right here
in place return none
so it doesn't create anything so when i
pass this it returns none
that's why i get none right here so
i need to then put this back
and i need to so i run that
then return
password pwd
ah one more problem this
is still a list so now i have to go
uh do do do do so this is a list we got
dot join
password bam
so now i have shuffled
rejoined i'm using my join
method on on a list for a string
and now i have these random passwords so
we have weak
we have strong now let's go ahead and
knock out
um now we need to deal with very
so we've we've handled a lot of this so
now let's go
all right
strength i'm going to type that pretty
good equals very
if num so now very
we want this to be very strong right
so we need to add a little bit more
of some some randomness to this
so ran
equals random dot
rand two
to four so right now
i don't even know how many digits it's
gonna have
it's gonna have two three or four so i
wanted to make this a little bit even
even even more more out of my hands
okay
okay
all right
all right so then we are now we need to
do
some a little bit of math uh here just
like we did with our two but now we need
to handle
we need to handle this so we got let me
see where i am with my notes
alright so and also to let everybody
know
that i've gotten pretty good at not
closing out the shell
and after the stream going over to my
github so you can get to my github
on any video link link on my
youtube channel and all of this is there
i have
one one full consistent
free codecamp dot py file that i keep
adding to
and then the notes the shell all the
notes all the output
for the day that i have in a file dated
uh today and that's in its own uh folder
uh free code camp folder over on my uh
github
server on my repository just to let
everybody know i have not been voicing
that as much as i've been meaning to
so all right where are we so we are at
we're at our if num then we need to
adjust this a little bit so now
all these others were just decrementing
down by two
well we need to set up some
functionality
we don't know how many digits it's going
to have we know
with an idea with a random number so now
we need to increment down by that
and then oops
then for i in range
of ran
oops then password
and increment up by
random choice
digit and then i come out so then i need
to shorten the length
by my rand
incrementation then for i
in range ran
so then also we're going to have random
punctuality too we're going to use that
same
that same uh for this right here
to really get some randomness
password increment random
random dot choice
punk'd and
for then we're just going to do some
letters
for n range whatever is left over
so if you want vary you're going to have
typically a very long password
random dot and then you could set some
function functionality up be like hey
and letter letter letter
all right
and i'm missing a there
boom boom boom boom
all right let's clean that up
some so now
copy let's go 15
and i we have very let's see how we did
check the any good comments
password equals password i love that do
you know that people actually
that's like the most used uh i think
there's a list there was an old movie
well i say old ancient to you guys old
to me
um it was called i think hackers back in
like 90
1993 or 1994.
had some uh pretty famous people in it
that hadn't been seen yet before
so all right
all right so here we go whoa let's see
where i got
what i left out
all right and ah
whoa well that's not good
let's see i left a whole bunch of stuff
out
length letter choice
and then increment up
random dot choice
and this is supposed to be length my
eyes are all over the place today
everybody i apologize
length choice
dot parentheses letter
there we go okay
oh you have seen that you are you are
right it had it did have angelina jolie
and a
couple a couple of others
it was a very interesting movie okay now
check
this out oh
good question all right so let's break
let's break this out
so what does what does this do right
here
it's all right help dot
string dot join
uh
str all right
help dot
str dot join my fingers are not
typing okay so this is a little odd
and you might you might go okay this
doesn't make any sense
because you're passing it a list but
you're getting a string most of the time
you have a string
and then you do something to it so let
me let me see if i can
do this right here so you're having a
string that you're saying hey
i don't want any spaces in it and this
is the
this is the list or the sequence that i
want to put
with this string that doesn't have
anything in it so if i were to
i know that sounds really weird so let's
look at this right here so i have a list
of a name that's sam
then i take name and i throw it in a
list
name so now i have name and it's a list
right
so now i want you to make a string
have zero spaces in it
and i want that information for you to
put in there with no
with no space is the list with the
contents
of that the contents of name now and i
can do
i can put anything in there i want a
space
so then i do join
name i get which happen to be
the characters of my name with a space
in between
now this is where it gets really handy
i want to put an asterisk between
all of the characters which happen to be
my name and again it's whatever string
you want
it's a it's a uh it's a reverse split
think about that
all right
yes it it it joins and it takes the
contents of a sequence
and then whatever here's the glue that's
what i want you to think about
because i remember the first time i was
like well why isn't join
a list method well it's not
because you're using this string
then that's a string and then this is
the method for this string
with this sequence there we go all right
really good question
okay uh let's see let's see let's see
all right cool i was hoping we would get
done
and um uh
shoot i did not mute the tablet i hope
that isn't too
too disturbing so i actually wanted to
go over we're gonna do a little bit of
bonus stuff
so let's go over some things that
just are random that i've had
on my channel that
um actually let me make sure that this
is everything that i wanted to
cover all right
yes let me check these notes right here
yep all right so you guys have maybe
seen
um packing packing and unpacking
well i want to show you this
let's comment that out so i'm going to
show you how to unpack
with a splat and zip so
let me just show you this
this is a little bit of bonus so we have
we have two lists
we have student
we have grade the grade that they're in
and we want to put them together
so i want to zip them together
classes equals list equals zip
so i'm going to zip just like a zipper
you put one side
to the other so i'm going to zip these
together student
and grade
so now i put this into memory
and i have a new list object
with tuples with
and it zips it one after another
so that is a very handy tool but
but now what happens if i wanted to
unpack this how would i go through i
could go in
and i could go and really
where how it's like i could i could chop
this up
well i remember when i first
saw this this was the coolest thing
so new student
students and grades
so now i can literally use the same tool
but i'm going to use
a splat character
splat classes
so i'm going to pass this back through
and this is how you literally unzip
so now i just unzipped
everything so now i have new students
and i have grades i remember that was
so i have grade and grades so i just
didn't type
the same we got new students and
students now
all right so that's that's bonus one
and i was looking through the other day
and i haven't done a very good job of
showing you guys
because it's basically kind of like the
question of hey what in the world does
that join do
because you've never talked about it
so now let's let's kind of look at some
string stuff right here
all right that's not the one i wanted to
see i wanted to see
this all right okay
x equals when i have it help help
all right put that into memory x
endur on x
i have all of these methods right here
check this one out i remember the first
time i was sitting this trying to solve
this problem it was a
just a silly thing to make to to to make
you think about it
help nope center we're already pulling
up help
okay ah return a centered string of a
length
okay so if i pass in center
and if i give what
let's see i can't remember let's do this
what does it do
is it in place or does it return it
returns
so we've got one of two ways so x dot
center
center equals
50. and then what do i want to have
around it let's do
let's do that so now check this out
so this is 50 characters and help is in
the center
okay that was one of the cool ones that
i liked
um let's see and we'll go we'll go over
more oh well that's not what i wanted to
do oh yeah sorry
i forgot i was in a different
application over here all right so now
here's another one
that i like a lot okay
oops okay comment this
out so now i have a list
of names and digits
integers
okay now
let's look at help dot
dir dot str
uh a i is uh what am i looking for
is upper is title is digit
is uh
is space
i'm looking for which one am i looking
for
is numeric that's what i wanted is as
key
is numeric so i want to create a list
of name
equals we're going to do some list
comprehension here false
if str
i
is numeric
merrick else
true for
for i and x
let's run this name
so boom so now
i go through and what i just did
is i took we increment we we go i'm
doing
for i n
x print i right
so then what i did is i wanted to look
at
because this was a string and it went
through
and i wanted to know the reason why i
did it like this is because
it knows if this is a
here integer integer but still
that is an integer just an as key
integer or numeric so that was that
now i cannot remember if we have looked
at the help the help prompt
on on any of these streams
jan uh cardinal
do you guys remember if we have done the
help prompt
because i'm sure with out of out of
these 400
so there are some people
that
uh okay so when you
when you don't pass in
an argument for help you get the help
prompt
and this is where python becomes
extremely powerful
so you can literally because this was
kind of like
my journey okay so then
okay so then you start bouncing around
and then you have
built-ins up
functions and then
uh what am i thinking about oh
keywords words there we go
oh okay so if you've noticed
that there's no way for you to run
help on some things because you can run
help on a function and on a method
right then
let's see what does four do oh
so there is a lot of documentation
on four okay so it goes through and it
so you don't have to re this is don't
try to memorize
anything understand what you want to do
sorry hint okay so then we're talking
about
range okay so so now
now you're going down this rabbit hole
so what is four okay and it has a
scenario range well what what's range
okay and then i got 83 lines of
range okay that that is the function
okay so
that is that is the function that has
the stop
or the three arguments so here's the two
here's the optionals and we just go from
there and you end up
going down this rabbit hole
keywords okay so what is this
what is this while
so then okay so i have this
and then uh what it what is then i'm
just bouncing around
none what is none and don't don't
confuse
don't confuse this because that's not
anything ah-ha so it's a
nun type so there we go guys
uh that is i was really hoping i'd get
to all of these things but
this is a super important feature
in fact that if you have a question
and you can't get it answered
anywhere jump over to my channel
drop it in one of the comments hit up
any one of us on discord and you're not
in this you're not in this alone all
right i believe in everything that
codecamp
is doing what quincy's trying to do with
bo uh
running the youtube channel uh we are
all to help you
here in your python journey and the
reason why
i make the micro videos is because i
remember
the journey that i was on trying to
learn
programming and i was all over the place
i'd see a video i'd do a video
i would try to remember where i saw it
every single
topic that i've covered here so far is
in a micro video
over on my channel you're not going
through this
alone all right so i just wanted to say
that
if you're spending time doing this
you're doing a very good job
all right and free code camp is here uh
i'm here you're not you're not dealing
with this by yourself
and you'll be able just sit down
type solve some code write some code
do a little bit of the time don't try to
solve the whole problem at one time
so all right guys there we go another
great stream
uh you guys are doing awesome i want to
appreciate free code camp make sure
you're
subscribing to their channel as well
joining if you can br buying any merch
great organization wholeheartedly
believe in everything
that they are trying to do so there we
go guys
another awesome stream today
and we will see you guys in two weeks
thanks everybody